JAMES GRIME: OK, so today
we're going to
talk Mersenne numbers.
So we have to pick one of our
Mersenne numbers to exemplify
the category.
Now, Brady always makes me do
this, so I've decided to pick
31, because by the time
you watch this
video, I will be 31.
So it's a nice personal
number for me.
So 31 is our example of
a Mersenne prime.
So a Mersenne prime is a prime
number to begin with like 31.
31 is a prime number.
A prime number is, as you
probably know, a number that
can only be divided
by 1 and itself.
The first few prime numbers
are 2, 3, 5, 7.
31 is a prime number, but it's a
special type of prime number
because it's one less
than a power of 2.
What are the powers of 2?
Well, you've got 2.
You've got 4.
You've got 8, 16,
32, and so on.
OK, so that's just 2 times 2
times 2 times 2 times 2.
That's the sort of thing.
None of these are prime numbers,
but let's have a look
at one less.
Well, 1.
Now, if I'm honest, we
don't say 1 is prime.
There's a special
reason for that.
But let's have a look
at the others.
3 is a prime number, and it's
one less than a power of 2, so
that counts as a
Mersenne prime.
7 is a prime number, and it's
one less than a power of 2.
Fantastic.
15.
Now that's not a prime number,
so that does not count.
And 31, there you go,
that was our example
of a Mersenne prime.
Now, there aren't many of
these Mersenne primes.
In fact, there's only
47 Mersenne primes.
Now, they start off
as 3, 7, 31.
The next one after
that is 127.
So let's have a look
at the next couple.
Powers of 2--
64, 128, and, well, this is
63, and that's not prime.
But this is 127.
That is prime, so it's one
of our Mersenne primes.
They're called Mersenne primes
because they're named after a
French mathematician called
Marin Mersenne, who was a
monk, a mathematician, and
a musician, and a fan of
alliteration.
His favorite cartoon
was Mighty Mouse.
His favorite film was Mad Max.
So he was in contact with a lot
of other mathematicians
around the world.
And he was trying to make a list
of this special type of
prime number, and that's why
they're named after him.
MALE SPEAKER: What are
they used for?
Are they used by
code breakers?
Are they used to make
better iPads?
Or are they just a game for
smart mathematicians like you?
JAMES GRIME: Well, prime numbers
are obviously very
useful to mathematicians.
They're famous, and they're
famous for a reason.
Mersenne primes are a special
types of prime number.
Something very special about
Mersenne primes, they are
related to the perfect
numbers.
We've talked about perfect
numbers before.
They were 6, 28, 496, 8,128.
They were known by the
Ancient Greeks.
They were given this idea that
they were perfect, unique.
Mersenne primes and the perfect
numbers are two sides
of the same coin.
Let me show you why.
If I pick a Mersenne prime,
let's call it M
for Mersenne prime.
OK, so M is our Mersenne
prime.
Times it by M plus 1, divide by
2, and that will give you a
perfect number.
Let me show you.
3 times 4 divide by 2.
That's 12 divided by 2.
That's 6.
That was the first
perfect number.
OK, let's try the next one--
7.
7 times 8, divide by 2.
That's 56 divide by 2.
That's 28.
That's the second
perfect number.
31?
Same thing.
31 times 32, divide by 2, and
that will give you the third
perfect number--
496.
And let's try 127.
127 times 128.
And half it, it's 8,128.
Two sides of the same coin.
Right, so you can help to find
the next Mersenne prime.
It's called The Great Internet
Mersenne Prime Search.
A great website with an
unfortunate acronym.
It's at mersenne.org, and
you can try it yourself.
Download the program.
It uses collaborative computer
power to find the next
Mersenne prime.
MALE SPEAKER: Why?
Why should I do that?
Why should anyone do that?
JAMES GRIME: For the glory.
For the glory.
Because mathematicians will
thank you for it.
Like the perfect numbers,
we don't know if there's
infinitely many perfect
numbers.
We don't know if there are
infinitely many Mersenne
primes or not.
So that's another open question,
something that
maybe, hey, you could
work out.
MALE SPEAKER: What's it going
to take to work that out?
How will that question
ever be answered?
JAMES GRIME: It's not
going to be easy.
It's not going to be obvious.
It's going to take a different
way of looking at things,
coming at it from a different
angle, something that other
people haven't tried yet.
Maybe not your usual school
math, but something else.
Whatever it is, something
we haven't tried yet.
MALE SPEAKER: The man or woman
who does that, what will it
mean for them?
If a man or a woman
comes up with that
proof, what will happen?
JAMES GRIME: If you do you come
up with that proof, you
will have glory thrust
upon you.
You will be famous for coming
up with such a proof,
something that has eluded
mathematicians
for hundreds of years.
MALE SPEAKER: Is it something
you can have a hunch about?
JAMES GRIME: Yeah, I think
technically we would have to
be Mersenne prime agnostic, but
it's definitely something
you have a hunch for.
Mathematics is done that way.
People think mathematics is a
dry subject, that is logical.
But people have intuition.
They have to pursue
their intuition.
So if you ask me, I would say
yeah, infinite number of
Mersenne primes?
Yeah, I would think so.
I might be wrong.